bonjour je m'appelle Lane fike Je suis directeur
des projets d'immobilisations pour cette Cuckoo
River Development Corporation ici à
Philadelphie et la semaine dernière, nous avons ouvert
cette promenade, elle était en construction
depuis deux ans et demi, nous avons eu beaucoup de
commentaires du quartier sur  à quoi cela
allait ressembler et comment
allait interagir avec le sentier existant le
projet résultant était bien plus que ce à quoi nous
nous attendions, il mesure 2 000 pieds de long,
c'est un passage de 15 pieds de large avec environ
quatre points de vue et il relie le
sentier existant qui  s'est retrouvé à Locust
Street et parcourt 2 000 pieds pour
passer sous le pont de South Street qui
est un lien vital entre le centre-ville de
Philadelphie et la ville universitaire avec
l'université de pennsylvanie et
drexel avec son projet c'était une
facture de rampe de 460 pieds au nord  côté pour
descendre et rencontrer la promenade, j'ai été
conçu pour résister aux inondations, il a
des lumières LED à énergie solaire, la raison en
était que nous ne voulions pas avoir affaire à
inondation du système électrique et
il est ouvert depuis environ une semaine et
il est déjà très populaire auprès du
quartier où nous étions ici dimanche
et l'endroit était plein à craquer